[Applaudissements]
c'est pas celle à l aller comme ça
assure l'échelle la bogossitude est de
plus en plus belle mes cheveux et très
belle en 2019 mais mes cheveux
j'aimerais peut la laisser répondre
c'était mes 39 ans nous faut j'attends
les 69
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ah ouais ouais ouais mais vous en dirai
plus un mec du maroc qui vient de se
faire voler sa pige aux 500 4 carats 39
ans machine vous êtes magnifique quels
sont vos résolutions pour 2020 je
commence j'ai fini 2019 avec vous avec
votre équipe j'étais super bien intégré
donc si bien que voilà c'est permettre à
l'aller ensemble c'est quoi ta raison du
soudan pour 2020 passer une aussi bonne
année avec vos canada parce que les gens
les gens savent pas qu'on s'amuse
vraiment c'est vraiment sympa vraiment
sympa je te prenais pour un con c'est
très agréable
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]